le monde de la culture est en émoi est
en effervescence après la nomination par
le Président Macron de Pierre-Olivier
Costa à la tête du musée marseillais le
Mucem
en effet plusieurs au fonctionnaires
spécialiste de l'art et de la culture
ont dénoncé cette nomination qui selon
eux du pur copinage monsieur
Pierre-Olivier costard ancien directeur
de cabinet de Madame Brigitte Macron
ancien chef de cabinet du président de
la République
ne répondrait pas aux qualifications
nécessaires pour ce poste alors madame
la ministre ma question est simple
qu'elles ont été les critères de
sélection retenues pour asseoir la
nomination de Pierre-Olivier Costa à ce
poste